this was a really weird time because
it's over because BLM was everywhere in
the UK the UK I mean in some senses is
further left and more woke than American
in other ways in other senses is the
opposite we tend to take our lead from
you guys
um something happens here and six months
later it's like all over the UK and BLM
of course that happened in the UK and it
almost doesn't make sense the statistics
and everything in the UK didn't really
make sense I think like three uh black
people over 10 years had been killed by
police or whatever it's a total we don't
have as many black people in the UK it's
a totally different thing but BLM went
crazy and then I had to go to like
soccer games right and I would see just
like the t-shirts have BLM all over them
BLM was written everywhere and I'm just
sitting there with my dad and that and
we're just watching it like as as Jewish
people we're like where's my where's my
decision in this because I know that the
organization I don't I don't have a
problem with the words black lives
matter but that organization the
anarchode Marxist uh anti-semitic thing
why do I have to watch that on my
football club now yeah it was it wasn't
nice to have to watch